Bonjour !
J'ai décidé de faire cette vidéo en plus des autres vidéos, pour répondre à vos questions.
J'avais déjà fait ça en 2007 :
Bonjour, c'est Cyprien dit MonsieurDream, j'ai 18 ans...
C'était... nul.
Je vous ai demandé de poser vos questions sur Twitter avec le hashtag #CyprienRepond
Et le hashtag est devenu premier des TrendingTopics dans le monde au bout de quelques minutes,
ce qui fait que vous êtes des malades.
On va commencer par la question qui m'a été posée le plus sur la planète Terre.
Je dois la recevoir au moins une fois par jour, par email.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi ça vous passionne tant.
"Quel est ton logiciel de montage ?"
C'est Final Cut Pro sur Mac.
Voilà, je ne sais pas si ça change quelque chose pour vous.
"Pourquoi, Cyprien ?"
.... bah parce que j'étais un enfant non désiré.
Et... mes parents me l'ont fait savoir en me donnant un prénom de merde.
Je ne vois que ça.
"Lis tu des mangas ?"
*hahahahahaha*
Oui.
"Quels sont tes mangas préférés ?"
Alors, c'est Dragon Ball et GTO.
Très largement, hein.
On va dire que ces deux mangas ont forgé l'homme immature que je suis aujourd'hui.
"Comptes-tu travailler à la télévision?"
Alors, j'ai déjà travaillé pendant un an et demi sur NRJ12,
j'avais deux petites émissions quotidiennes.
Et j'ai arrêté pour pouvoir faire des vidéos sur internet.
Et je pense que c'est beaucoup mieux comme ça, en tout cas moi je préfère très largement,
je préfère passer du temps avec vous, tout simplement.
"T'aimerais toucher les seins de Nabilla?"
Est-ce que tu aimerais toucher deux ballons en plastique.
Tu as ta réponse.
"Qui est ton youtubeur préféré?"
Alors je dirais que c'est TomSka.
C'est un Anglais qui fait des vidéos et des films d'animation totalement absurdes,
et je rigole très très fort, beaucoup.
Et en France je pense que c'est Suricate,
parce que ces gens ne sont pas normaux et... ça me plait.
"Franklin, Michael ou Trevor?"
Trevor, parce que c'est un dangereux psychopathe.
"Qu'est-ce qui t'as donné envie de créer la chaîne CyprienGaming et pourquoi avoir choisi Squeezie?"
Alors, j'ai toujours été passionné de jeu vidéo,
j'ai même fait des dessins pour parler de l'actualité des jeux vidéo, en 2006 sur un blog.
Et puis j'ai découvert la chaîne Smosh Games qui est la chaîne gaming de Smosh,
et peut être les youtubeurs Américains les plus connus.
Et je me suis dit mais, il faut vraiment que... comment dire...
que je crée moi aussi ce genre de vidéo, parce que j'avais envie d'en faire depuis toujours.
Et voilà, donc j'ai crée cette chaîne où il y a des vidéos chaque semaine
et si j'ai choisi Squeezie, c'est parce que je cherchais un youtubeur gaming qui se mettait pas mal en scène.
Je voulais faire ça avec quelqu'un qui se montrait pas mal et qui faisait pas mal le con.
Pas qui filmait juste son écran en train de jouer...
et donc c'est tombé sous le sens.
Et je pense que Squeezie est, pour moi, le meilleur youtubeur gaming.
"Comment fais-tu pour te masturber?"
Comme ça.
"Tu fais quoi chez toi lorsqu'il n'y a personne?"
"Quel est ton sport préféré?"
*Acclamations*
"Tu seras à la Paris Games Week?"
Oui! Si j'ai pas trop de travail à ce moment là, mais normalement, oui.
"Tu mesures combien de mètre?"
Tu m... combien de mètre?
Alors, désolé de te dire ça comme ça Monsieur, mais vous avez des problèmes avec les distances, hein.
Alors si tu veux là, je viens de pêcher une truite, grande comme ça.
1.5 km je dirais, à peu près.
Donc je mesure 1,79m, pour répondre à ta question,
qui est une taille plutôt moyenne... c'est comme 1,80m, mais en moins bien, voilà.
"Pourquoi tu portes des lunettes?"
Ben heu, parce que si je les enlève je vois comme ça.
Ce qui me semble évident, que j'en porte donc.
"Plutôt blonde ou brune?"
Alors, plutôt brune, même franchement brune,
même si tout le monde sait, hein, que mon genre de fille ce sont surtout les
dégueulasse, édentée, bien grosse, avec des croûtes entre les bourrelets, un œil de verre et qui boite.
"On t'as dit que tu ressemblais au mec de CyprienGaming?"
N'importe quoi, il doit pas me...
OH PUTAIN!!!
"Pourquoi?"
Ben... très bonne question, hein, je...
C'est marrant, on dirait un petit peu une question de disert de philo, un peu
Pourquoi?
Vous avez quatre heures, hein.
*Hors caméra*   Monsieur?
Oui
*Hors caméra*  Pourquoi?
*Hors caméra* Vous avez quatre heures.
"Aimes-tu frapper ton pénis sur des objets durs du style: table, chaise, chihuahua, Cortex?"
Comment tu sais?
J'adore MonsieurDream, Norman, Squeezie, Jérome, je me marierai avec vous plus tard.
Alors déjà, ce n'est pas une question.
Et je crois que c'est interdit par la loi.
Et enfin. "Peux-tu nous faire ton plus beau twerk?"
NON!
*musique hip-hop*
Voilà, merci pour toutes vos questions, hein.
Malheureusement je n'ai pas pu répondre à tout, parce que ce n'est pas humain, tout simplement.
Et si ça vous a intéressée, ben, n'hésitez pas à le dire dans les commentaires,
comme ça, j'en referai d'autres par la suite.
A bientôt!